the nude photo scandal that's rocking
the Marine Corps is far bigger than
previously known the Defense Department
is investigating multiple online sites
men from all branches shared intimate
photos of women including fellow service
members Jayne Crawford is at the
Pentagon the Defense Department is
investigating a website called Anan IB
where like the name implies users can
post messages anonymously Paul's older
abroke the story for Business Insider
it's an image sharing board where male
military members from all branches were
sharing nude photos sharing Instagram
accounts in order to cyberstalk and
generally harassing female service
members across the military some posts
showed photos of clothed women but asked
for something called wins they would say
Fort Bragg anybody have any wins and
wins on this forum means nude photos the
scandal was uncovered over the weekend
when a photo sharing Facebook page
called Marines United came to light that
site showed a photo of Erica Butner with
a message requesting anyone with
explicit images of her to post them she
read a statement to reporters on
Wednesday as a rape survivor I can tell
you that this exact behavior leads to
the normalization of sexual harassment
and even sexual violence after the
Marines United page was taken down
Marines United 2.0 appeared officials
say they've now received reports of at
least half a dozen other sites the top
enlisted man in the Marines sergeant
major Ronald green has told Congress
that Marines United is just the tip of
the spear it's not just affecting the
Marine Corps this was the Navy Air Force
and Army as well it's nothing different
from stalking I mean all it is is
stalking with a computer now a
spokeswoman for the Marines told CBS
this morning quote we fully expect that
the discovery of Marines United will
motivate Marines to come forward to
notify their chain of command of pages
like it things may seem to get worse
before they get better in the Army Navy
and Air Force say they also are
investigating Gayle I'm sure hope so
thank you very much Dan